hi everyone it's jerry this is game nine
from the 2021 fide world chess
championship match between yon nyo
pomnishi playing on the white end
and magnus carlsen
going into game nine carlson leads five
to three in this race to seven and a
half
an interesting start to this one
the ceremonial move was interesting
it was played by the young star from
india pragnanda
he went with c4 and that was the move
that stuck
this was the first time nyopomnishi
played something other than one e4 in
the match
we have an english opening as a start to
this game none
in just a few moves however it will
transpose into something else
e6
g3
d5
and an immediate bishop to g2
this is inviting black
to play
d4
since white doesn't have the pawn on d4
black can play d4 himself carlson does
and with it
we enter a
reverse
bononi structure
play continues with knight f3
some attention on the d4 pawn
the knights reinforcing that point
black can also reinforce d4 with c5
however
this would subject
black to gambit play
namely
the bononi gambit
in reverse white up a tempo
b4 can follow
and we have this typical opening of the
lines on the queen side and white
looks to
interact well with the bishop on the
long diagonal
getting an open b file maybe an open a
file
okay black doesn't subject himself to
this
possibility no gambit play
knight c6 instead some development
castles bishop c5
d3 knight f6
and after knight b to d2 this is where
we have
a5 notice the timing of this a5 move
when
is it played
only after this knight has played to d2
if for example
white played rook e1
and then black played here
this wouldn't be such a great choice
this knight could then think about going
to a3 and b5
so a5 is played at a moment when
black knows the knight doesn't have
quick
a quick track into the b5 square
it can be tough to address a white
knight on the b5 square
if you have the a5 move in
this is another reason why
black wouldn't play a5 until you would
see first a3 right a3 prepping b4
black was will often wait to see a3
before playing a5 himself
all right well in this game it's the
queen knight going to d2
a5
knight b3
now where should this bishop go
you want to stay on this diagonal
reinforce d4
or do you drop back to
e7 in the game the bishop goes to e7 i
had a look
about
you know what's going to happen if the
bishop goes on this diagonal if it stays
on this diagonal
well first of all if it's on b6 it's
subjected to possible
c5 moves
and
if it goes to a7
that's a problem because
white can play this move that looks
super anti-positional to to weaken b4
but it does stable it would stabilize
the knight on b3
and white can look forward to putting
pressure on this pawn
and this would be extremely difficult
for black to parry
i'm not i'm not quite sure how you go
about defending that a5 pawn
so
if you end up having to play b6 the
bishop's dead
so there's problems
if the bishop stays
on this diagonal
a4 is a good follow-up
so the bishop goes to e7
now e3
this is white knows that when he goes to
b3 this this knight will this night's
post will soon be questioned
right around the corner
there's a4
so e3 another this is an important
moment
the structure can turn in a couple
different ways
black in this game captures on e3
but another move i thought maybe
possible is e5
and
black can experience some problems
for sure if you're going with e5 if if
there is this train of thought that says
you know what i put a pawn on d4
sure you're putting pressure on it but i
wanna i wanna maintain a pawn on d4
there's an issue
there's gonna be some pressure
placed on black's position
if black went with e5 and allowed this
structure to surface
uh what's the issue exactly well
white can follow by getting to this open
open file the bishop's pinned playing a4
the knight gets to go to
c5
so let's say black castles
and this move again
shows up
a4 is a good move an important move to
be familiar with here once more super
anti-positional
a knight a bishop
can be making use of this square
but this knight is stable on b3 this is
the primary function behind a4
and because the knight's stable
there's pressure on d4 still
and white already has some possible
tricks
to capture away on d4 and maybe
in the end after the queen recaptures to
take the bishop
i believe one of the continuations is
bishop b4 here
we have a dark square bishop exchange
and
uh
if if a move like h6 is in white is i
think close to winning this position
believe it or not
not up any material but this is
excellent black has space
but this is not space with advantage
these two minor pieces will not find it
difficult to find good squares of course
this guy's
awesome
and this knight is contributing look at
that a5 pawn
out of nowhere hit three times defended
once
okay my point here is that entering this
particular structure is not a wise
choice for black
because of the eventual
a4 move
okay
what is played d takes e
bishop recaptures it's accessible to the
knight this is an open position the
bishops are valuable
black goes hunting
like it's out of that threat
offers a bishop exchange
black does not initiate it
instead he castles
certainly a move
black was considering here how much time
did he spend before castles close to 10
minutes
this was most likely a move he was
crunching the numbers on
if a4 is in there
white has to first
capture here and only then move the
knight
in in a position like this
it's roughly equal
this pawn is
sort of uh well it's not contributing
let's say when it's on d3
what white should be looking to do from
here is move the knight and get this
pawn up to d4
so let's say we put the knight on a good
square f3 this guy needs to get rolling
otherwise it may
be clamped down on with c5 and rook d8
and yeah it may never be able to get to
d4 successfully so this is a possible
way forward
if
black went with this direct move a4
instead of castles
on move 11.
okay castles
d4
and now this knight doesn't have access
to d4 anymore so this is where the the
knight is given a kick first the
bishop's exchanged now knight c5
this pawn does support that move
but
how stable is the knight on c5
there are some tricks
potentially against the d4 square
undermining the knight's support
not just yet first we have a3
another interesting moment is this one
right here how exactly to react to a3
in the game we had b takes a3
considered one of the better moves
surprisingly enough
is b form
giving the b pawn away for what reason
let's have a look
knight takes b
rook b1 this would be poison
queen b3 and the knight is hunted
knight c6 and here's a pretty cool
variation after rook b8
can you spot a fancy move for white in
this position
feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
knight a5
seems like it's hanging
knight takes knight you would drop the
rook though
and rook takes rook would be met
strongly
by knight takes knight
and we're ready to take the queen with
check
anyhow this b4 move really sharp
um if this pawn isn't captured
rook d8 and let's say rook d8 there's
rook b1 rook e1 the white pieces are
doing really well
maybe black
needs to go ahead and take that pawn if
b4 is on board
a reason to
uh give up this b pawn
is
well
for one you're not allowing
the black rook to activate so easily
and also you're not giving black access
to the a3 square
i'm not sure what
good follow-up square this queen has
but as we'll see in the game when you
capture on a3 this queen has a as an
easy time
entering white's house
b4
there's complications for sure
not so easy to get that black queen
involved
okay in this one b takes a3
rook d8
knight b3 so for example instead of
knight b3 if rookie one here's that
tactic
sweep the leg
and after the recapture we get the
knight
that's a problem for white
so
the knight goes back
this the knight on c5 was vulnerable
this guy right here is unprotected
they both retreat
better squares more stable squares
over key one now that this pawn is
pinned
queen gets out of the way
recapturing the pawn
queen e2 natural enough
flight square for black
and now h4
so carlson had a
had a decent think here he came up with
bishop to d7 about 12 minutes spent on
this one
i believe one of the variations black
needs to consider
at this point
is the possibility of this pawn
pushing up to g5 and questioning the
knight
not just yet
because he doesn't have support of g4
but this knight is soon going to move
and the bishop will be unleashed
and the queen will be watching over g4
so this possibility is nearby i believe
this h4 move is hinting at creating a
duo and then
playing g5 so
he needs to be careful
bishop d7 is on board
95 follows
and the bishop falls back to e8
if
black is capturing the knight
that's no good
because the pawn recaptures and now
there's a problem on both f6
and b7
so black is prepared to meet knight e5
with bishop to e8 and we see that
reflected with the times he
had that worked out
carlson knew this move was coming
the bishop falls back so there's some
good coordination the rooks are
connected
c6 is secure
uh the follow-up here is queen to e3 but
i'd like to highlight a couple key
variations
let's first kick off with this one
where black
ends up with
isolated queen pawns
what's the assessment of this one
equal
it's difficult for either side to
improve
this pawn is passed because of this
capture
but the a2 pawn
with it still being on its home square
it feels more so uh
liability rather than an asset
i also like
this knight on f6 better than the one on
b3
and
the possibility for h5
granting the knight
a new option to advance
and put some pressure on
the f2 square primarily
i think
you know offsets
any any positive that may be connected
with white having a past a pawn
again it's a difficult position for
either side to make great improvements
on
we don't have knight takes night
the other variation i wanted to
highlight and i believe it's maybe the
other another one that carlson had to
consider prior to bishop to d7
is this idea of
a caveman-like attack g4 go this is the
all-in move
it's either working or it's not
this this would not be working but i
want to put some moves on to
show
the resources that black has
this rook
is an excellent piece
sure g5 is in there
and yes this knight will have to find a
new home
but
in the end whose king is really the more
vulnerable
probably the white king
look at the queen and the rook
and even the knight doing a good job
converging on the h3 square
this is probably one of the best pieces
in the position
an excellent defender and attacker
this is a great position
for black
something that needed to be considered i
imagine
okay
in this game it's queen e3
black improves the their queen just a
bit
this is defending b7
which allows for this capture and at
least you don't have to deal with bishop
takes on b7
also some pressure on c4 this knight is
not
always going to be around to defend c4
from here rookie b1
knight is captured
queen takes knight queen takes pawn
so it's pawn takes knight knight ds or
not knight d7 knight g4
forward attacking the queen
proceed with caution though this knight
on g4 doesn't have a good square in some
lines we have the offer of a queen
exchange so for example
if queen takes c
f3 and the knight is dead
or
instead of queenie one of queen e2
you have to babysit the knight with h5
this is fine for black the knight has a
new path
if ever kicked with f3
okay in the game the offer of a queen
exchange
queen takes rook takes once more
f3 to trap the knight
h5 is on board
the b pawn falls rook is hit
white is up a pawn
however
the black pieces are super active
the rooks are better than their
counterparts also
the knight on g4 is better than the one
on b3
this pass pawn again not felt
as a
great positive in this position
from here how do we address the threat
on c4
after rook to a4 what do you do here
considered one of the better
continuations is to play f3 drive the
knight back
and then put this guy on e4
so basically do nothing about
this
rook takes pawn idea
this is a i would say a best piece in
the position it's on a stable square
currently cuts out the flight square
it watches over the knight jump into f5
white has the option to knock the knight
out if it arrives there
and we go from here the
this is not an issue
for white if black gets the pawn back in
this way
because white can challenge this rook
considered best is to keep the rook
around on a4
if you exchange white would be doing
very well
not a great way to defend this pawn
rook c8 there's bishop to b7
yeah there's a problem on c7
okay in the end f3
and then bishop to e4
considered best
the move played in the game says i don't
want to even
allow you to take my pawn
white plays c5 and when i first saw this
during the live stream i thought to
myself
okay white's a step away from playing c6
the bishops defended
but at the same time it would be stuck i
said to myself
it wouldn't have any move right it's
it's defended
it's watching over maybe that promotion
square right
it's a long way off before that pawn
gets rolling
also the c5 square opens up if white's
able to play c6
there's a big problem though with c5
and that was a huge this move was a big
blunder
the reply c6
this guy's stuck
a huge oversight
by team white
there's no good way to now save this
bishop this is where we had a huge jump
in the evaluation
started to register as about a minus
three
that's the win of a piece and this guy's
toast
how do you save it
there's no saving it
let's see what the attempt is these two
rooks can attack it twice and at most
it could be defended once
so
when c6 was played nyopnishi wasn't even
at the board
and he didn't return until about
20 minutes had passed
i'm sure he saw it from a distance
uh you know he he knew the move was
played while he was away from the board
recognizing that he made a serious error
he played f3
knight h6
rook e4
black doesn't exchange rooks
he puts pressure on the bishop
if you exchange rooks
you'd be letting white off the hook
because the bishop has access to a6 and
the knight would have access to a5
but with the rook still around
on the a file
that cuts out
any minor pieces going to the a file
rook b4
follows it's hit a second time
it's now in a pin
it's lost
the bishop is lost
but
white tries to
create some problems in the only way
possible
and that is to get the a pawn running
so let's see this
attempt to complicate
first a4
rook b6
interesting approach
gives up a pawn
in order to grant the knight access to
the c5 square
it's immediately made use of
knight f5
a pawn gets running the rook has to at
some point blockade so back it goes
continues to push
and from here
black ends up capturing on g3
another approach is to forget about pawn
grabs and immediately focus your sights
on the a6 pawn
and a way to approach it can be with
knight to d2
and i'm not sure how to
even make a
an improving type move for white let's
say king f2
defends upon at least
the idea here is to plant the knight on
b5
and i'm going to make some back and
forth moves just to illustrate how
white can
eric's me black can improve their their
pieces this would be the idea
to eventually
put the bishop
the knight and the rook all on the a6
pawn
there isn't really a great way to
stop this approach i know i was going
back and forth here but eventually with
the knight on b5 it's only ever a blink
away
from hitting that pawn
and it's it's it's down it's going to
fall after a7 knight b5
it's hunted
so
some attempt with the king approaching
like this
that's not going to work out either
but in this game it's not knight d4
instead he picks up a pawn knight takes
g3
knight a4
and
you have to be careful there are a
couple moments upcoming where black has
only moves to maintain a winning
advantage
so with knight a4 we have c5 giving the
pawn back
primary function vacate c6 for the
bishop to assist in stopping the past
pawn
a7
there's only one winning move here for
black
and it's rook to d8 important to stay
out of the way of knight b6
with tempo
knight tag c5
was the move played in the game if rook
b won
during the live stream i thought is the
approach here to now play bishop c6
and meet rook b1 with rook f8 this would
be a good way for black to lose
here's why
i thought it felt a bit off and it is
off
to have these pieces in a restricted
state
knight c5
and let's say the knight comes here
knight b7
uh
that hurts
ready to promote bishop takes knight
rook here
soon the rook returns
white will be promoting
and another variation suppose the bishop
goes here
let's say in this position
instead of knight f5 if the bishop goes
to a8
now there would follow knight d7
ouch
big problems for black there as well so
what am i getting at what would be the
idea what is the win for black
if rook b1 is played
the win here is for black to give the
piece back
rook a8
and after rook b8
there would follow rook takes pawn
white gets the bishop
and
black is up upon and soon
going to be up a second pawn all base
points are covered
black wins the second pawn and yeah
there's
i don't think there's many more
complications
from this point on
so it can be tricky
if rook to b1
is in there
knight takes c5
instead and after rook a8 this game goes
no further
team white resigns
carlson goes up now
six to three
in the match
a huge lead
uh it's
clear what the approach will be
if play did continue from this
from this position
with the pressure on a7
this rook is tied down to defending
and all black needs to do
is put the knight on e7 c6 and take a
pawn
the knight is secure on c6
white really can't interfere with this
approach
so
this one goes no further
a huge lead now
for carlson
let's have a look at
the tail of the tape on this one
there we go and we can see clearly the
big blunder
there was only one blunder in this one
no inaccuracies mistakes or blunders for
carlson and just the one blunder
is all it took
with move 27 c5 and also what is this
game well no this is the first win
in this match with the black pieces so
three wins in fact
over the past four games
huge
a huge victory for team carlson he only
needs a point and a half before he
defends his title for what would be a
fourth time
tough tough road ahead for nippon nishi
that is for sure
anyhow
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section
below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you